the Conservative Party has been fighting
over Europe for decades mr. chairman you
have invited me to speak on the subject
of Britain and Europe it was brought
down three Tory Prime Minister's in a
row and could yet a fourth the issues at
hand of morphed but the fissures remain
unaltered Tuesday's vote is but the
apotheosis of a 30-year civil wars
rather like sending your opening batsman
to the crease only for them to find the
moment the first balls are billed have
been broken before the game the question
is why how did the party which took us
into Europe not only infect itself with
bitterness and bloodlust but spread the
contagion to the rest of us and will it
ever stop the Tory party always had a
Euroskeptic gene but it was a minor one
for much of its modern history it was
keen on Europe and expanding access to
continental markets towards the late
1980s for some tourists that began to
change the European Union was hell-bent
on a course that ever closer Union
leading eventually to a United States of
Europe so much that we were doing was
counter to what was going on on the
continent there it was essentially Derry
gist and here we were trying to
deregulate Margaret Thatcher herself
agreed with heavy lambasted the idea of
a European super-state
in her 1988 speech but perhaps these
nascent divisions would never have
become as wide nor as faithful had this
talismanic Tory not been deposed in the
way she was because of the fall of
Margaret Thatcher it was a traumatic
reaction to that there's discontented
hard rain right-wing elements in the
party were deeply annoyed that she had
fallen from power and he gave them fresh
impetus to moving the party into an
empty internationalist anti-european
attitudes suddenly to be a Euroskeptic
was to be a Thatcherite to embrace her
vision of Britain and to fight for it
after she'd gone made worse after the
ERM debacle
still living with that the labels have
changed but the division is the same
from John Major ah woods Tory prime
ministers have attempted to bridge that
divide by splitting the difference it
has seldom worked for long one of his
critics once said that he liked a
cushion always bore the imprint of the
last person that had sat on him they
didn't want to upset their right-wing
colleagues my sounding as though they
thought there were benefits in the
European Union but maybe Tory leaders
were working with what they had because
of a bigger problem connected to but
bigger than the party's European issue
the last time the Conservative Party won
a decent majority was when Margaret
Thatcher was waving at that window on
election night in 1987 perhaps that
gives us a better way of understanding
brexit and the civil war it is the
culmination of 30 years worth of
Conservative Party underperformance in
the country a general elections Tory
Prime Minister's would never be sober
Holden to their Euroskeptic rump if
they'd won decent majorities since the
fall of Margaret Thatcher conservatism
has been undergoing an identity crisis
both with different understandings of
Britain's place in the world both with
different ideas about how a party with
the nation and its heart responds to a
world where the nation-state
has never seen less important but with
the vote tomorrow can the wounds of this
civil war at last begin to heal I
believe the Conservative Party will heal
it's the Conservative Party is a party
of very considerable resilience and it's
healed many times in the past we face
years of this until the Conservatives
actually do somehow pull themselves
together or some group they found that
will establish a consensus and a
majority some grown up we're proceeding
but civil war will not be ended for some
years if as I believe we leave with a
clean break and we then begin to build
our country up again we begin to run our
own affairs again and that is successful
and I believe if it can be successful
then I think the party was heal
happy thing historians will rate the
Conservative Party's performance over
this period if we were to leave Europe I
think they will be very unkind they will
talk of a nation one of the greatest
empires the world has ever seen
overwhelmed by newly emerging forces a
nation clinging on to memories of a
power structure quite impossible to
replicate without a vision as to how to
build on the incredible strengths that
made us what we were into a force
relevant in the 21st century and they
will they will be scathing the
Conservative Party has governed us for
75 of the last 119 years its ability to
agree is of paramount importance to the
nation for until they can reconcile this
great European question